what's up everyone it's Warren and we
have some big news to go over today
specifically a leaked video that could
have a huge spoiler for Avengers in-game
in it so I must issue a spoiler alert if
you do not want anything spoiled for
Avengers in game you might want to click
away now we'll be going over a video
where a celebrity could have potentially
revealed a character's death and
Avengers end game so if that sounds like
something that you don't want to know
you should click away now also a
reminder about my giveaway giving away 5
imax tickets so you and some friends can
go see Avengers in-game if you'd like to
interfere your chance to win all you
have to do is subscribe to my channel
like this video and comment down below
with your thoughts and your favorite
superhero or villain alright if you're
still with me there is a leaked video
that Serena Williams the professional
tennis player took at the Oscars the
video is of Chris Evans at the Oscars
but it's not what we see in the video
that's a big spoiler it's what we hear
I'll go ahead and play the video so you
can all see it and hear it pretending to
do a selfie so she could get
devastated that he died and
did you catch that did you hear what her
and her friend said so they're
pretending to take a selfie because they
want to film Chris Evans because they're
a fan of him but then she says that
she's devastated that he died in the
movie Avengers and immediately after she
says that her friend cuts in and says
that it's supposed to be a secret
so did Serena Williams just revealed to
us that Captain America dies in Avengers
in game many people believe that it's
true the recent brothers have already
came out and said that they've screened
Avengers in game a few times already and
that was a little bit ago so they've
most likely screened it a few more times
since then and usually when they screen
movies like this they do invite some
celebrities to see it so there is a
chance that she could have seen the
movie already plus she originally posted
this video to Instagram but then she
removed it a few hours later it's most
likely that somebody told her to remove
it but not before some fans could screen
record it so to me one of three things
could be happening here one is she could
be referring to another Avengers film
which doesn't really make sense because
he's never died in a movie unless she
thinks that he's one of the characters
that got dusted but that still doesn't
really add up why would her friend tell
her that it's supposed to be a secret if
she's talking about a past movie and
again why would she take the video off
of Instagram if it's not supposed to be
a secret which leads me to my second
point of what could be happening and
that is it's real he actually dies an
Avengers in game and she has seen the
movie but the third thing that could be
happening here is that this is very
intentional she could have been asked by
Marvel or the Russo brothers to
intentionally put this video out there
intentionally say those things and then
intentionally take the video down it's
something that I definitely wouldn't put
past the Russo brothers because they're
trying to keep us from really knowing
anything about this movie so this could
be misdirection
but I do however think that the most
likely scenario is that he dies and she
somehow knows and now she has spoiled it
to the world but again I wouldn't put it
past the Russo brothers or Marvel to go
to extreme lengths to keep people in the
dark about Avengers in game so let me
know what you think about this in the
comments down below do you think serena
williams dropped a huge spoiler by
telling us that captain america dies an
avenger
in game or do you think that it's
something else let me know in the
comments down below and again don't
forget to subscribe comment and like the
video so you can enter the giveaway and
stay up to date on everything relating
to Avengers in game and Marvel as always
thank you all so much for watching
woof woof
[Music]